When I think about entrepreneur and
what I want in entrepreneurs,
it's a great question because
it at the end of the day,
an entrepreneur is
full of contradictions.
And the people that
are really those great,
great entrepreneur that I'm looking for,
they're very strange people because
let's take a few of
these contradictions.
To start with, these are people
that are what we call alpha dogs.
They run, they stop,
they brake for no one.
They know what to do at any given point.
On the other hand, they're never
that good if they can't take advice.
But it's pretty much in contradiction
because these people that just run
forward, they're usually not
the ones that take advice.
Well, great entrepreneurs are.
When you look at entrepreneurs,
there are people that are very smart so
they understand that the chances of a
startup to succeed are roughly 1 out of
20 because that's the statistics.
On the other hand, the great ones
never believe that they're going to be
the ones failing, they know that
they're going to go on succeeding.
Again, they're creating
their own reality.
And the third thing is that,
these entrepreneurs, they wake up in
the morning, and they know 100% that
they're going in the right direction.
By the afternoon, they can pivot
the company because they ran into
a new piece of data that forced them to
change their view, but they will wake up
the next morning again, being 100%
sure that they're running in the right
direction, which is a totally
different direction than yesterday.
And so these qualities are basically
the main qualities that I look
in entrepreneurs.
When I find the ones that are like that,
these are the one hour meetings, right?
These are the one hour meetings,
and after that I say hey,
that's a perfect personality
fit to be an entrepreneur.
I don't care what your field.
You may pivot, for all I care, 20 times,
but I want to be part of that journey,
because that's a person
that's going to succeed.
That's an entrepreneur that
has everything it takes.